so on saturday morning i woke up with
the apple watch ultra charged up to 100
battery drove to practice i had ultimate
frisbee practice out in new york a lot
of people don't realize how many
calories you burned during a three-hour
practice but there you go finished that
drove home and then went about the rest
of my day i ended that day going to
sleep with about 69 battery nice then
slept with the watch on for sleep
tracking then woke up on sunday morning
with 60 drove into new york city again
had another practice this one a little
hotter sun's baking a little more three
more hours and 2 000 calories later that
was over drove home went about the rest
of my day again
and then again i slept with the watch on
for sleep tracking woke up on monday
morning drove to the studio now it's
monday morning 11am at the studio and i
currently have 20 battery lift
it's pretty good that's two days and two
nights and into the third day which is
far better than i've ever been able to
get out of any other apple watch period
but
let's rewind for a second
[Music]
so we knew something like this was
coming we knew there was going to be an
upgraded ruggedized apple watch in some
way and i think a lot of people sort of
assumed it would be called the apple
watch pro but instead we got this thing
and it's called the apple watch ultra
the thing is though it would have
actually been totally reasonable and
probably kind of perfect if they'd also
call this the watch pro and that's just
because of the way apple treats the word
pro nowadays like apples toss the name
pro around the highest end versions of
almost all of their products iphone pro
macbook pro
airpods pro ipad pro pro display and
each of these expensive devices has some
set of features that a smaller fraction
of the population can actually take
advantage of and use now whether that
makes you a pro or a hardcore user or an
enthusiast or a wannabe pro like what is
a pro airpods user anyway that's a
debate for another day but it's the same
thing with this apple watch ultra i've
been using it for about a week now and
the way i think about it is there's a
core group of people for which the apple
watch se actually covers all their needs
and that's like most of the population
but then there's an additional group a
little bigger than that for which the
standard apple watch which is now series
8 covers all of their possible uses so
you know it adds the always-on display
the different sizes etc it's already a
really versatile smartwatch but there's
still some people around the outskirts
for whom the regular apple watch still
wasn't enough and apple naturally still
wants those people so this is an 800
watch that has some extra premium
features and specs that are amazing and
definitely overkill for most people like
the ones in the middle of my
illustration but it's attractive for the
most extreme users the adventurers who
go on serious hikes or go diving or run
marathons or do triathlons so there's
really three main things that they added
to this watch over the regular one which
are ruggedness
features and battery and they all kind
of go hand in hand for ruggedness well
it's pretty obvious they just beefed
this thing up so it's now much bigger 49
millimeters diagonally but it has the
shapes and materials now of a watch that
should be much harder to break it's a
titanium case with a ceramic back it has
much bigger buttons that don't have
quite as much travel as i expected but
they are easier to press with gloves
there's the bigger crown and then the
crown guard on the side here it's a very
distinct look and then the display at
the top here is a flat sapphire crystal
instead of the normal curving over the
edges with this slightly raised lip all
the way around the screen so it's
protected from corner impacts to me
it's pretty huge like this is a pretty
massive watch i will say it is not
nearly as heavy as it looks which is
pretty nice uh but it does visually
stand out for a couple of reasons one
this is the only color so this is the
exposed titanium it looks very silver i
wish it came in black because black is
slimming like you can make a black watch
look smaller with a black band but that
would admittedly require black paint
which would probably get like scratched
and then the silver would show through
and then it would look pretty gnarly
after a while so i get it maybe they
could anodize it i don't know but yeah
big silver watch on skinny wrist looks
big but then also two this shape
see like this is a big watch to me
someone who wears pretty much only smart
watches right and smart watches are kind
of weird shapes sometimes like
it's a computer on the wrist type of a
look it's sort of just a block but in
the overall watch world the apple watch
ultra is actually nowhere near the
biggest watch you'll see like some
people are very used to much larger
watches on their wrists actually and
especially those people on the outskirts
i was talking about earlier they're
fairly used to wearing some of these
massive garmins or suuntos or even
specialized activity specific equipment
like dive computers that'll make the
apple watch ultra look compact so the
whole like this watch is huge thing is
very much up to context but the thing is
like a lot of these watches here are
bigger than the apple watch but they are
watch shaped they're circular up front
and then they have this taper around the
wrist at the top and the bottom so they
don't look like they stick out nearly as
much even though they do
where the apple watch just
doesn't taper at all it's just like a
block so yeah the computer on the wrist
thing
i don't know i actually don't mind the
aesthetic like i said i just wish it
came in black that would have been nice
i wonder if
colorware is going to be able to paint
these things anyway that's the build
quality but the other two things that
make the ultra ultra are battery and
capability
battery being pretty simple it's a much
bigger watch and it has room for more
battery inside but we'll get to that in
a second but the capabilities just come
in the form of extra features so the
extra microphone and extra speakers for
better audio quality in windy
environments the dual frequency gps for
more accurate and reliable gps and
tougher settings like forests or in
cities between skyscrapers the wr-100
water resistance rating for submersion
up to a hundred meters the new 2000 nits
max brightness for this display which
means it's the most visible outdoors
that i've seen a smartwatch oled plus it
makes for a nice flashlight if you need
it and most importantly the new extra
button so that bright international
orange colored button is called the
action button and it can be mapped to
right now any one of these eight things
so i currently have mine to just open
the new workout selector i pick the type
of workout and then hit the action
button again to get it started and then
once you're in an activity there's again
a layer of customization to what this
action button can do so maybe marking
segments or laps inside a track workout
or marking when you switch from the bike
to the run in a triathlon all kinds of
stuff like that i really like having it
i did feel like i accidentally pressed
it a lot just because of the way i
grabbed the watch and adjust the crown
but i pretty quickly got used to that
too i think the most noticeable thing
that this apple watch has over other
apple watches is gonna be the battery
life so this like i said from the
beginning two full days and two full
nights with plenty of room to spare
that's easily better than it's roughly
double what i was able to get out of my
apple watch series 7. the thing is while
it is a massive improvement for an apple
watch
it's still nowhere near the other
highest end watches which many of them
are expected to go weeks months
even years without even thinking about
charging this one right here this casio
watch it's a casio right casio pro trek
uh which has solar charging
has
never been charged it is virtually
infinite battery life it didn't even
come with a charger in this watch world
a two-day battery life is not that
impressive but really that that brings
me to the ultimate question with this
ultra which is
how are you going to be using this watch
like if you're one of these people on
the outside here that doesn't use an
apple watch apple was trying to find a
reason you didn't use it and add the
features or capabilities to make you
actually want to use it now because of
course they want to bring you into the
ecosystem so some of these people over
here like these are frequent scuba
divers and they've been using dedicated
dive computers ranging from giant watch
to tablet on the wrist to track depth
and directions and a bunch of other
safety metrics underwater
now the apple watch ultra has added that
wr-100 water resistance up to 100 meters
there's a new dive app to track some
pretty basic stuff like depth and give
you times for safety stops on your way
back up for recreational diving things
like that but then apple also partnered
with a third-party company for this
oceanic plus app that's coming later
this year that seems to do basically
everything that the pro dive computers
do including air integration pretty much
the only thing it doesn't do that some
extreme technical divers might want is
tank pressure monitoring and depth
monitoring past 40 meters now some of
these people way over here these people
are really adventurous hikers like not
the normal beaten path casuals finding
popular hikes on google i mean these
people are going off and carving their
own path for miles and miles in the
middle of nowhere sometimes for days at
a time so the watch ultra has got now a
bunch of navigation related features
there's dual frequency gps for more
accurate pinpointed gps even in
challenging locations but then the new
compass app is pretty impressive it lets
you set unlimited waypoints so that you
can navigate back to them at any time
and you can track your exact walking
path with a backtrack feature in case
visibility is difficult or you need the
watch to guide you back where you came
from there's also a super loud 86
decibel siren that can play from the new
speaker system if you find yourself
completely lost with no one around and
yes it is actually impressively loud and
you can hear it from probably a quarter
mile away and there's a new wayfinder
watch face by default that sort of puts
all the stuff right at your fingertips
including a live compass that's super
smooth i think a lot of people just
leave this face on all the time even if
they don't need it but then some of the
other people up over here are ultra
endurance athletes and of course the
name sort of speaks for itself here
honestly the apple watch just didn't
last long enough for these people's iron
man races and ultra marathons and
spartan races
so
the new watch ultras got the dual
frequency gps which is huge and the
action button is nice too but the
significantly improved battery life is
huge for these now it's not going to
last a week or a year like some of the
stop watches or simpler ones do but now
it's just about double the battery life
of the standard apple watch and it's
finally up to the task of some of the
most extreme gps heavy endurance
athletes and even if it isn't apple has
mentioned that there's this
battery optimization setting feature
coming later this year
that it's not the low power mode that's
already existed in the watch but it's an
extra setting within workouts to ping
gps and heart rate less often so in a
normal workout for me which is it's a
disc sports workout for an ultimate
practice basically it's just it's
measuring heart rate constantly like
every few seconds which is super helpful
you can see how quickly you recover you
can see when you're in certain heart
rate zones during the course of a
practice but if you're running like a
hundred miles or something ridiculous
you don't need multiple pings every
minute you just need a broader sense of
how it's going so that's a helpful
feature for these people and when you
turn that on it should essentially
triple the life of the apple watch apple
says up to 60 hours i don't have it yet
because it doesn't exist so i can't tell
you exactly how well it does but that's
a useful feature they even have a trio
of new 99 bands for this watch for these
activities so there's a trail band which
looks kind of sick then the alpine loop
and the ocean band as a reviewer i want
to like i want to test all these
activities and like go okay i guess i
gotta run an ultra marathon now and like
scuba dive but i can't remember the last
time i was
10 meters underwater let alone 40. so i
can't test all of this stuff but
actually reached out and heard directly
from these people on my podcast the
waveform podcast i'll link the episode
specifically below the like button so
you can listen to it but i had on a
diver
an ultra runner and an alpinist so we
asked them about the risk computers they
currently use and whether or not they
think this apple watch ultra is good
enough to replace them
and through those conversations one by
one they each came to the end with
basically the same conclusion which is
that yeah it looks like they kind of did
everything that they were looking for
out of an apple watch i'll link it below
so you can hear exactly what they said
and then there's me so you know
i'm a tech reviewer and an ultimate
frisbee player so turns out the normal
apple watch is actually enough for me
like i said a normal ultimate workout or
any sort of training we do is typically
just a ton of heart rate readings
there's not a bunch of gps pings or
elevation tracking or anything like that
so it's not super demanding but still on
the ultra i'd get to reap the benefits
of the battery only running down 20
during a practice instead of 40
and then the more accurate gps readings
and the brighter screen are kind of nice
to have on other activities maybe the
occasional bike ride or a hike or stuff
like that and it might be better for you
too it's one of those things where i
think generally if you have to ask you
probably don't need it but it really
reminds me of the rog phone like that
thing is complete complete overkill for
almost every human on the planet with
all its crazy gaming features and
absurdly high-end specs but also all
those features for gaming also happen to
make it better for media and regular use
and it's basically the same thing here
like this is technically speaking the
best apple watch they've ever made it's
got the longest battery life the biggest
brightest display the best microphones
and speakers and it's all in this most
accurate tracking package yet i mean if
your wrists are big enough
then yeah you can daily this too it's
kind of put itself in this unique
category where it's replacing some of
these extreme like dive computers or gps
watches that you'd normally take off
when you're done with your workout
uh but it's an apple watch through and
through at the end of the day you can
wear this thing every single day i just
don't know if you can like
dress this thing down as much as you
could a regular apple watch like fun
fact i wore the apple watch series seven
in midnight with my tux at the met gala
and it didn't look
insane to me anyway uh get a nice you
know watch band with it like the leather
one at shopdownitemphd.com
it all works out great but yeah this one
just because it's so
it just sticks out it's massive all the
time you can't really hide it as much
might have a little more trouble with
that but hey if you know what you're
getting into the rog phone is a pretty
good phone and if you know what you're
getting into
the apple watch ultra is a pretty good
apple watch
so that's been it
thanks for watching
catch you guys the next one peace